across the country the US military also
also risking their lives are on the
front lines in this fight against the
corona virus this pandemic is also
taking a toll on servicemembers who risk
their own health to help all of us
defense secretary mark esprit joins us
now to talk about that part of this
different story good to see you mr.
secretary thank you so much for taking
the time to be with us we do appreciate
that so again thank you for having me no
we're very glad you're here so we're
hearing about military health care
workers that will now be deployed here
in New York City to relieve the workers
here where exactly are they going and
what will they be doing
sure Gail first let me say how proud I
am of the 50,000 plus American
servicemembers who are deployed around
the country helping their fellow
Americans and as you noted many of them
are certainly deployed from their own
homes their own families but they're
also risking their own their own welfare
or their own health to help their fellow
Americans so I'm very proud of them the
department defense every step of the way
has tried to stay ahead of the curve
ahead of need and I think we have since
going back to January we've also tried
to be very agile and adaptable in terms
of how we respond to the to the state
and local governments I've had several
conversations with Governor Cuomo and
mayor de Blasio and we've been working
very well together and I appreciate the
mayor's kind comments in the past couple
of days with regard to the medical
professionals in New York City as you
know we got about 2,500 doctors nurses
and others in the city that includes a
thousand on the Comfort a couple
thousand I'm sorry a thousand at the
Javits Center and then we've deployed to
11 New York City hospitals 350 doctors
nurses and respiratory therapists and
today we'll be deploying another 300 to
help those local hospital workers who've
been struggling mightily to keep on top
of the cases help them out provide some
additional relief from the department
defense you know mr. secretary hear you
say you're proud of them but it's always
interesting to me they're proud to do it
they want to do this they want to get
out there and help and risk their lives
that's the definition of a true hero to
me yeah they really do and many of them
if you look at the National Guard who
were the first to deploy we have over
30,000 now deployed across the United
States and they're coming
from there's those homes and communities
and then as we've had the deep start
reaching into our reserve forces we've
actually had many doctors nurses and
others just volunteer to come back on
active duty or volunteer for active duty
to serve so again I'm very proud of them
they have my highest respect and regard
for what they're doing today across the
country
well the biggest outbreak that we're
hearing is on the aircraft carrier the
Theodore Roosevelt there's 1,900
servicemen overall but 400 are on the
aircraft the Theodore Roosevelt what
steps are being done to protect the
servicemen there and on other in other
places yes so we have a less than 10
percent of the crew is infected and all
but one are mild to moderate cases so I
think the Navy is taking a lot of
prudent steps to get that under control
the most important thing right now is to
take care of our sailors make sure
they're getting the care they needed and
and then get the ship back to sea
so it can perform its its wartime
mission and like I said the Navy's been
pushing supplies out there doctors we've
been able to get thousands of the
sailors off the ship and taking care of
ashore and I've spoken with the Acting
Secretary the Navy and the Chief of
Naval Operations and I know they're
doing everything they can to make sure
we accomplish those two missions and
talking about the acting Navy secretary
the Bret Crozier resignation has been
widely discussed you have certainly been
asked and you have answered your
thoughts are also widely known but there
does seem to be new information today
the new the Navy chief says that he
appears to be open to reinstating Bret
Crozier depending on the outcome of an
investigation depending on that outcome
are you to open to reinstating him well
look what I replaced the acting Navy
secretary three days ago I called him
and the Chief of Naval Operations into
my office I gave him some guidance one
of the things I told them is this no
further action will be taken against
captain Crozier until the investigation
is completed and once that's completed
we'll see where that takes us and so
we've taken nothing off the table what I
look to do is hear from the chain of
command my inclination is always to
support the chain of command and and to
take their recommendations seriously so
we'll see how that plays out at some
point here in the coming days they will
come to me and share with me their
findings and
commendations is it ever okay to break
the chain of command or protocol this is
a career officer when he thinks lives
are at stake
does that matter I'm just curious yes so
following the chain of command and
maintaining operational security is very
important in the in the military there
are always a you know extreme cases
where going outside the chain of command
makes sense that's why we want to see
where this investigation takes us but I
will tell you you know the last time I
spoke to the Chief of Naval Operations
we have over 90 ships at sea right now
and none of them have any problems that
are no infected crews so again I'm
confident that overall the Navy is
taking prudent steps to maintain the
health of our sailors and to ensure our
warships are ready to go mr. secretary
what keeps you up at night when it comes
to coronavirus you've got a lot on your
plate like everybody who's handling this
I know you're working 24/7 what keeps
you up at night on this you know it's
like many governors and mayor's have
said that the biggest challenges the
medical staff is making sure you have
sufficient doctors and nurses and then
for me because I have these mobile
capability inherent in the military is
to maintain adaptability and be agile so
as as the governor first called for
building hospital capacity New York City
the next day I sent the Corps of
Engineers and they began building out
the Javits Center when the governor of
the mayor asked for the the mercy ship
we had already been preparing her
anticipating this so we orbital quickly
get her out of maintenance and up into
New York City Harbor and then of course
as we converted the Javits Center from
non Cova da Kovac we adapted very
quickly and now in the past few days
when I spoke to the mayor about a week
ago he said I need doctors and my
hospitals I said mr. mayor we'll get it
done and that's why we began shipping
hundreds of doctors and nurses there so
we got to remain flexible and agile you
know right now it looks like Seattle
will release the army field hospital
that's up there 250 bed capacity we're
gonna look at another place around the
country to to send that because right
now we have forces deployed in new New
Orleans
Dallas we're looking at Massachusetts
Chicago or other places around the
country that are in Meade all right
secretary esperan we see you're on top
of it flexible agile and let's add pivot
to that pivot is a really big word these
days thank
you sir for your time we really like you
Gil take care of yourself